ALAN SEALES: The winner of five
2015 Tony awards, including
best musical, "Fun
Home" is based
on Alison Bechdel's best-selling
memoir of the same name.
This groundbreaking
production introduces us
to the character of
Alison, and herself
at three different
ages, revealing memories
of her uniquely dysfunctional
family that connect her
in surprising new ways.
And here to perform
with us today, please
welcome all three Alisons--
Gabriella Pizzolo,
Emily Skeggs, and Beth Malone.
[APPLAUSE]
EMILY SKEGGS: Hi, Google.
It's good to be here today.
So I'm going to sing a
song from the show called
"Changing My Major."
It's the moment in the show
where the college-age Alison
has woken up and
she has just slept
with a woman for the first time.
[MUSIC - FUN HOME, "CHANGING MY
MAJOR"]
[SINGING "CHANGING MY MAJOR"]
[APPLAUSE]
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO: Hi.
There's a moment in "Fun
Home" when Alison and her dad
are in a diner, and Alison's
dad says, go find the waitress.
And on Alison's way
to find the waitress,
she sees a woman who
she identifies with.
[MUSIC - FUN HOME, "RING OF
KEYS"]
[SINGING "RING OF KEYS"]
[APPLAUSE]
BETH MALONE: Hi.
I am them grown
up, older, and I'm
writing a book about those
moments in my life now.
And so as I investigate
my past, the memories
sort of become all-encompassing.
And this song takes place
in a car with my father
when I'm Emily's age.
But I have remembered
it so fully,
and it has sort of put me in the
present in the car with my dad
at this age.
[MUSIC - FUN HOME, "TELEPHONE
WIRE"]
[SINGING "TELEPHONE WIRE"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - FUN HOME, "IT ALL COMES
BACK"]
[SINGING "IT ALL COMES BACK"]
BETH MALONE: Caption--
every so often, there
was a rare moment
of perfect balance
when I soared above him.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: Keep it going.
Five 2015 Tony wins, including
best musical score, and best
book, and of course
best musical.
And so it was adapted from
Alison Bechdel's graphic novel,
which, in real
life, the story is
about the character of Alison,
which the three of them
play over various times.
And recreating, basically--
it's essentially
a graphic novel autobiography,
right, more or less?
LISA KRON: Yeah.
I mean, it's a memoir,
so I think it's maybe
a subtle distinction.
But I think as opposed to
an autobiography, which
is about telling the story
of things that happened,
I think in a memoir
there's something
essayistic about Alison's work.
And I think she's
interrogating questions
about who her father was,
about her relationship
with her father,
and about memory,
and the relationship of memory
to what actually happened.
ALAN SEALES: So how did you even
come across the graphic novel?
LISA KRON: Doesn't that
sound like a fun musical?
ALAN SEALES: It does.
[LAUGHTER]
And it actually is funny.
We'll get to that.
JEANINE TESORI:
It is very funny.
ALAN SEALES: But how did
you find the graphic novel?
What light went off saying, oh,
this needs to be on Broadway?
JEANINE TESORI: Well, the words
triagiocomic graphic novel
memoir--
LISA KRON: I mean,
come on, people.
Come on.
JEANINE TESORI: Musical comedy.
Bam, bam, bam.
Well, you know,
Lisa sent it to me,
and I don't know if any of
you have read that book.
I had not, I'm
embarrassed to say.
And as soon as I read
it, I thought, oh my God,
that's going to be
a fantastic musical.
It really sings.
Getting there is
going to be hellish.
And it was, because the
book is so beautiful,
and you have to-- at
one point, I think,
when you're adapting
something, you
have to what my
friend calls there
has to be a lot of
spit on the page,
when you actually spit at
the very thing that you love
and make it your own.
You have to render
that person invisible,
like actors render us invisible
when they-- though we're
very visible, they
render us invisible
when they're on stage, as
if it wasn't ever written,
it just always was.
And that was the trick with
that book, the pressure.
ALAN SEALES: I mean, so you
found the book and you read it.
But what was the
point when you said,
I want to turn this
into a Broadway show?
BETH MALONE: A Broadway show.
ALAN SEALES: A Broadway--
JEANINE TESORI: I never thought
this show would be on Broadway.
I mean, let's be real.
ALAN SEALES: Did you not?
JOE: No.
I've been doing
this since I was 19.
I was at Columbia and
then I played in the pit.
I've seen what goes to Broadway.
It was not this show.
I thought you just fell over.
I was like, oh my God.
I meant, it was
always meant for-- no,
I just think that Broadway has
cracked open in a way that--
BETH MALONE: Sorry,
I'm upstaging,
because that's what I do.
[LAUGHTER]
JEANINE TESORI: Beth, what
are your thoughts on that?
BETH MALONE: You
know, basically,
when I first received the
script from my agent--
[LAUGHTER]
I was like, this is going
straight to Broadway
and it's going to get me my
Tony nomination, finally.
And that's exactly
what happened.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: And that's
all the time we've got.
Thank you guys.
JEANINE TESORI: Yes, goodbye.
Thank you.
I have nothing more to add.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Well, so
what were the challenges
on getting it from your
concept onto the stage?
JEANINE TESORI:
Well, look at us.
[LAUGHTER]
The challenges-- you
guys take that one.
BETH MALONE: What
are the challenges?
JEANINE TESORI: Yeah.
BETH MALONE: Well, OK,
so who's read the book?
Anybody?
Yeah, it's like--
you've got to read it.
Yeah, you should read
it, first of all.
But first of all, it's really
dense and it's really literate,
and it does a whole bunch
of things because she can.
Like, each chapter focuses on
a different literary character,
and she does all kinds of
literary masturbatory things--
I mean, fun but awesome
things, because she
can because she's a genius.
You know, she's like, I'm going
to make this chapter this,
and I'm going to do
all these things.
And you're going to need a
thesaurus to read this book.
Well, that kind of stuff doesn't
translate into scene work.
A lot of the scenes, all
of the scenes that you see,
don't exist in the book.
So they had to be
created completely
out of the situations and
the need of the people
in the moment to
try to figure out
what happens on a day when this
is what the scene is about,
and no one's talking about
what the scene is about.
What do they talk about?
So there are all kinds
of crazy obstacles
to getting to the
version that we have now.
It was insane.
EMILY SKEGGS: Or
a scene would be
built around one small
panel of the book.
One little line and one tiny
drawing, an entire scene
would be built.
BETH MALONE: My suggestion
is to just read the play
and just take apart line by line
just the tree-planting scene.
This is my favorite.
I mean, I love the
tree-planting scene.
LISA KRON: I'm not sure that
would be interesting for them.
BETH MALONE: Well,
for me, if anybody
is interested in how dialogue
works to inform you on what--
like, look at the-- you could
go-- all the information you're
receiving visually, you have to
receive through conversation.
That seems natural
and intention based.
It's crazy what we had to do.
LISA KRON: This is
sort of a nerdy theater
conversation that's
happening sort of between us.
And I think the graphic
novel is extremely literary.
That being said, it is
extremely accessible.
It is-- what Alison understands
about the dynamic, engaging
mechanisms of that
form have made
her a master, an acknowledged
master, in that field.
So it's a book that when people
read it, it's the kind of book
that then they give to
everybody they know.
They'll buy it for
everybody in their family.
It's an incredibly moving book.
There is nothing about
it, about the way
that it functions, in the way
that it draws the reader in,
that operates in any
way that's related
to the way a drama operates.
So we had to take it apart.
And it's such a beautifully
made masterpiece
that it was very difficult
to take it apart,
because I would try to
read it just to figure out,
what are the events
in theatrical terms?
And I would find myself
90 pages in again,
pulled into the story.
It was really difficult
to stay, to resist
the beguilement of
that book enough
to even see what it was made of,
to see its constituent parts so
that we could then make them
again in this different way.
It was incredibly laborious.
Usually if you can figure out
what the mechanism of a piece
is-- it's very difficult
to figure it out.
I always think it's kind
of like throwing a pot.
You have to-- as I understand
it, not that I'm a potter,
but you have to center the
clay exactly on the wheel.
And if you do, then you can
pull it up and make any shape.
But if you're not exactly
on center, as you pull it up
it's just going to go
wonky and fall apart.
And that's what making
plays is like a little bit.
But plays are much
more forgiving.
But a musical--
ALAN SEALES: But this
is your first musical.
LISA KRON: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
JEANINE TESORI: Yes.
And Lisa won the Tony
on her first one up.
I must say, I had to
write six musicals
to get that [MUTED] award.
But yeah.
LISA KRON: Obvious we're
meant to work together.
JEANINE TESORI: It's so true.
We actually met
writing this musical.
LISA KRON: Yeah.
JEANINE TESORI: And
now we're together.
No, I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
LISA KRON: Exactly.
JEANINE TESORI: I don't know.
It's that clock.
It makes me feel pressured to
say things that aren't true.
ALAN SEALES: That's
more for me--
BETH MALONE: What
does that clock mean?
ALAN SEALES: That's my cue
to know when to wrap it up.
BETH MALONE: Oh, OK.
ALAN SEALES: So I
know people have
to get on with their day jobs.
We could sit here forever.
We'll just have a
private conversation.
They can all do their thing.
LISA KRON: I keep waiting
for the temperature.
ALAN SEALES: OK, Google,
what's the temperature.
JEANINE TESORI: Super cool.
Super cool.
ALAN SEALES: Jeanine,
you're actually
the most prolific and honored
female theatrical composer
in history.
BETH MALONE: But can we
just remove the word female
from that and just talk
about how many musicals
she's written, and one of
the most prolific composers
in Broadway history, OK?
[APPLAUSE]
First of all.
Thanks.
ALAN SEALES: And mic drop.
So what was it
personally for you
that made you want
to work on this show?
You've done so much,
your career is so vast,
that what was it about this?
JEANINE TESORI: I grew up
in the '70s, and I'm very,
you know, tall, grande, venti.
And that to me is me.
Not as nice shoes, but we
grew up at the same time,
the same time as Alison.
And I remember in the '70s and
thinking through Tiger Beat
and all of that stuff that
no one here will know about,
which is so frustrating.
But I remember being Gabby's
age looking at my parents, who
were interesting people.
And there's a whole
inner life, I think,
that gets stored
versus the outer life.
And that's where a lot of
musicals, I think, live.
When you look at a lot
of things when people-- I
hate the adage, when you
can't speak anymore, you sing.
I was like, I don't
know what that means.
What I do know is that we
all have these inner lives,
and when you think about your
relationship to your parents
right now and what it was, and
then what it was and what it is
and what it will be,
there are all these songs.
And a lot of that
genetic material
is musical genetic material.
We are themes and
variations of each other.
There's no way not to be.
And so what we tried
to do-- and musically,
when you look at classical
music does it all the time,
you take something,
a statement, and then
you rework it and you rework it.
And that metaphor of throwing
the pot is exactly right.
And you think of
all of the shapes--
Bach did it, Mozart did it
beautifully, all of them.
And then at the very end,
why they call it the tonic,
is you come home.
You come home again.
And that's what musical
long form is based on.
So this show absolutely
fell into the path
of coming home to yourself
and being changed by it,
the way that "The Odyssey"
works and so much of literature.
And it's such a smart
structure, this one.
So I was desperate to do it.
And I felt the
pressure for it to be
really as great as the book.
LISA KRON: As literary
as the book is,
I think what both of us sensed--
I mean, what I have learned,
and Jeanine already
knew this, and we
had a little conversation
with George Wolfe early on,
and he articulated
this in a way that
was extremely helpful
to me and I think to us.
He said, you know, a
musical can be as complex
as you want it to
be, but there has
to be one primal desire
that starts the engine
and drives through every
single moment of the musical.
And I think what we
sensed was in the book
and what we put
into the musical is
that there's a primal desire.
It's the first lines
of the musical,
Gabby comes out and sings, and
she sings it in the finale,
as you heard, and Beth is
writing it, Daddy, hey Daddy,
come here, I need you-- the
primal desire of a child
to make a physical
connection with her father,
in this case a father
who is very withholding,
and that desire, which
everyone has a relationship to,
no matter who your parent is.
If you didn't know your
parent, you know that desire.
It's a primal need.
And it's in the book.
It's what makes people feel
the way they do about the book.
And it's a perfect
core for a musical.
ALAN SEALES: So I'm gonna
shift gears for a little bit
over to Gabby here.
How you doing?
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO:
Good, how are you?
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: I'm good.
So you came from "Matilda."
You were in "Matilda" before
this, right, so some of you
may have seen her as Matilda.
[APPLAUSE]
Wonderful job.
So obviously that show has
a completely different theme
from this.
So for you personally,
what attracted
you to want to play Alison
in the show, small Alison?
Tall Alison.
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO: It was
just such beautiful writing
and music.
And I could just imagine it
going on when I heard it.
And I absolutely loved it.
And I was like, I need
to invest more in this.
I need to see what it's about.
I just have to go
and see the show.
I just felt very connected
to it as soon as I heard it,
like it touched my heart.
ALAN SEALES: So there
is also, I think
one of my favorite
numbers is what
you do with Cole
Gray and Zell-- Zell,
is that how I say his name?
JEANINE TESORI: Zell.
ALAN SEALES: Zell, yeah.
Zell Morrow.
So you have two
brothers in the show.
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: And there's
this amazing dance number.
You guys have not seen it.
I mean, the show
itself is great,
but God, these three kids
on stage blew my mind.
Is that your favorite
part of the show?
It's a showstopper I'd probably
say every night, right?
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO: I mean, there
are a lot of show stoppers.
But that one--
[LAUGHTER]
But that one especially
is very fun to get to do.
ALAN SEALES: Do you look
forward to that every night?
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO: Yeah.
Yeah.
I love getting to do
it with Zell and Cole.
They're great.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, it seems
like you guys have fun together.
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO: Yeah, we do.
Fun at the fun home.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
at the fun home,
which is actually
a funeral home,
for those of you who don't--
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Emily, you were
one of the original members
of the show, right?
EMILY SKEGGS: I joined
the show off-Broadway.
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
So one of the
original Broadways.
And then you took a hiatus to
go film some TV stuff, right?
EMILY SKEGGS: I did.
ALAN SEALES: So what
have you been working on?
EMILY SKEGGS: I filmed
a little guest role
on the show called "Salem,"
about the Salem witch trials,
but the witches
are really witches.
And then a complete turn,
I filmed a miniseries
called "When We Rise."
It's going to be on ABC.
If you saw the movie
"Milk," it follows
three political activists who
were kind of in his periphery
from '72 to 2009.
So they're sort of calling
it the gay "Roots."
ALAN SEALES: So it also has--
[LAUGHTER]
--it also has the LGBT kind
of theme going through it.
So what about that
attracted you to that role?
Did it have anything
to do with, of course,
your Tony-nominated
performance in "Fun Home"?
EMILY SKEGGS: It's
kind of crazy,
because both in "Fun Home"
and in the miniseries,
I play a real-life person
who I could speak with
and get to know and
study their lives
and study how they got from
one point to the other.
And that's just been
kind of mind-blowing.
I mean, to be able to
map out the arc of a life
and the main events
in someone's life
and what brought someone
from here to here
and the desire that made
them fight for something
versus something
else, is-- I mean,
I think I'm still so
much inside of it,
so I don't quite understand
the significance of it,
if you know what I mean.
Like, these people
are really alive.
And now we are
taking their lives
and showing it to other
people who are really alive.
I get very emotional
when I think about it.
ALAN SEALES: What did you
say, it's a stoner thought?
EMILY SKEGGS: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Whoa, so, we're, like,
alive, and we show things
to other people who
are also-- yeah.
EMILY SKEGGS: But it's exciting
to honor people's lives
in that way.
[LAUGHTER]
LISA KRON: I said to
Alison one time, I said,
Alison, what is it like when
you go to other musicals?
Are you like, there's something
wrong with this musical-- oh,
it's not about me.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
I just didn't relate to it.
ALAN SEALES: Boring.
Gosh, I have so many questions.
But if any of you guys in
the audience have questions,
there's mics here,
so start lining up,
and we can go to
you guys any time.
I want to skip over some
things because there's
so much to talk about.
So the format of
the show itself is
in the round, which, for
those who don't know,
the audience is sitting 360
degrees around the stage.
And that's very, very
unusual for Broadway.
And this is now
the third staging
of the show, the previous
two not in the round.
How did it get to where it
is, and why does it work?
Why did you choose this version?
Anybody?
JEANINE TESORI: Yeah, Sam--
ALAN SEALES: Sam the director.
JEANINE TESORI: We did
it-- a thrust stage,
and then proscenium
at The Public.
Part of it is Sam loves
working in the round.
Musicals are almost never in
the round because of the way
that sound design is.
You know, just think that you
have to look at someone often
to be able to--
like at a concert,
to watch someone play you
listen to it very differently.
And when the image is
removed from the sound,
it's much harder.
But the sound design by Kai
Harada and the technology--
we're at Google,
so you know, is so
amazing you can throw this
imagery onto the stage.
And even if that person isn't
there, it's like they're there.
And that's a whole
new age for us
at musicals, because
you can do it very,
very differently than the
traditional proscenium
arch, which requires
that there is focus.
And you can do it
really differently.
It's also a memory play,
so this fits beautifully
inside that idea that memory can
come and get you at any point.
It's getting me right now.
So the people who are in
power are not the actors.
It's the audience
who's in power.
ALAN SEALES: It was
interesting to me
because halfway
through, I realized
that I felt like I was
literally inside the mind
of the storyteller.
It is Broadway-sized, obviously,
it's an on-Broadway show,
but it feels very intimate.
And the stage itself, there's
the living room of the house,
and then there are times
when the whole furniture just
shifts, so we see
different sides of it.
And I feel like it just worked
so incredibly well to convey--
I was reading, I won't take
credit for this terminology,
but the swirling of
the memories going on
and the recollection of
the character of Alison,
because the whole
thing is a flashback.
So there's no question there.
BETH MALONE: But it doesn't
necessarily behave in the way
that your memory play that
you're used to seeing behaves.
So it sort of loves to make
you think you know how it works
and then switch
the rules on you,
which is kind of-- the
thing about memories
is sometimes you're
like, oh, yeah, that,
and sometimes you're like, what?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wow, that.
So the memories
don't come at you
and behave the same way from
memory to memory or moment
to moment in this play.
And it's helpful.
And also it's cranium-shaped.
Ultimately the circular-- it's
like the inside of your-- you
went on the amazing journey
into-- you know what I mean?
JEANINE TESORI: I love that.
Raquel Welch.
BETH MALONE: We're
on a red blood cell.
JEANINE TESORI: We are
so old, because no one
knows what we're talking about.
ALAN SEALES: No,
I love that movie.
"Inner Space," is that
what we're talking about?
JEANINE TESORI: "Fantastic
Journey" with Raquel Welch,
where they go in--
ALAN SEALES: "Fantastic Voyage"?
JEANINE TESORI: Thank you.
Oh my God, you have to see it.
And then they get attacked
by a white blood cell.
BETH MALONE: Yes.
JEANINE TESORI: She
wears a jumpsuit.
It's so amazing.
ALAN SEALES: You had
a question over here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
wondering, Alison Bechdel,
did she participate in
the writing process,
or did she just
hand you her baby?
And did she like the end result?
LISA KRON: She
handed us her baby,
and she made herself available.
She gave us her journals that
she wrote-- me and Jeanine,
she gave us her journals
that she wrote while she
was writing "Fun Home."
And she was available to
answer our questions which
came up in the writing.
But then she really trusted us.
And it was, indeed, like
handing us her baby.
And she, yes, I
think unequivocally
feels very positive
about the show
and I think very
connected to the show.
And on the night I think,
we opened at The Public,
or maybe it was
around that time,
and she said, I don't
know what to do.
She expresses her
gratitude a lot.
And she said, I feel like I
should give you my first born.
And then there was
this sort of pause
and we looked at each other,
and we were like, well,
you did already.
ALAN SEALES: You did, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: First of
all, thank you so much.
The performance was amazing.
Really appreciate it.
So this is a question primarily
for the three Alisons.
This is obviously a very
deeply personal story.
I mean, I haven't read the
book or seen the whole show,
and just those three songs were
giving me the feels back here.
ALAN SEALES: All the feels.
AUDIENCE: All the feels.
All at the same time.
But my question is, for
you guys as somebody who's
interpreting this deeply
personal experience
and then projecting
it for other people,
how do you tap into that?
How do you personally
approach making
that accessible to
people like me, this lump
sitting in the back of the room?
EMILY SKEGGS: Yeah,
I think there's
a lot about the story
that's really specific.
But the end of the day,
it's a story about a girl
and her relationship
with her father,
with her sexuality.
And I think it's pretty safe
to say that we all have fathers
in some way, shape, or form.
And we all have some kind
of desire for other people.
And so I think that just
keeping that in mind.
And it's about empathy.
It's about finding a
connection with these people,
these real, live
people, that-- you know,
Alison has a struggle
with her father,
but they both have
the same struggle.
Another stoner thought for you.
BETH MALONE: I love it.
EMILY SKEGGS: Do you
know what I mean?
BETH MALONE: Yes.
For me--
EMILY SKEGGS: It's
about connection.
BETH MALONE: Yes.
EMILY SKEGGS: They
have the same struggle,
but they don't know
how to talk about it.
BETH MALONE: There's
a lot about being
in the show that lends itself
to the actual material that is
like, I don't want to do that.
I don't want to go.
I don't want to
watch this scene.
I don't want to watch it.
I don't want to have to watch
him leave these kids in a New
York apartment
while he goes off.
I don't want to watch this.
And that actually is helpful.
There's a lot about
being in the show,
and you have to give-- you
must give yourself over to it.
To be in the show,
there are things
that you're going to
not want to have to do.
But that's exactly the journey.
That's the exact
journey of Alison going,
whoa, I wanted to make
this piece of art,
but I didn't know it
was going to do this.
I didn't know it was going
to take me here and there.
And that's the same as kind
of being in it sometimes.
It's like, wow, I
really wanted this.
I really wanted
to make this art.
Agh, it's awful.
But it's wonderful.
So there's a lot of, at that
moment to moment thing, when
the show starts, da
da, da da, da da,
and you just kind of
walk through that door
and it just kind
of sucks you in.
And the moment to moment
work of the composers
and the lyricists
and the book writer
have given us sort of a
template where we just
have to step out on
stage, and it takes you
right down the road.
EMILY SKEGGS: The material
is like a pull of honesty.
BETH MALONE: Yeah.
It's like there's no
fat left in this script.
I did an interview yesterday.
Somebody was like,
well, this version
of the character-- I'm like,
there's just no character left.
It's all just--
it's just intention.
That's all that's left.
It's like there's no-- it's just
an elegant, streamlined person
voraciously searching for
something a minute at a time.
So that's all it is.
LISA KRON: I think what
we're trying to do,
what theater makers
try to do, is
to make something that
will do what you just
described, is to
give an audience,
to evoke feeling
from an audience.
And it costs us something
sometimes to do it.
But the thing is
made out of craft.
And so what you feel
and what we have made
are actually not the same thing.
We make this sort
of vessel of craft
that then takes you someplace.
And it should feel-- you
shouldn't think about that.
You should never
think about that.
We also want to
make you-- we want
to make something that is lean
in the way Beth's talking about
so that you never--
the goal is for you
to get picked up and
carried somewhere,
and never be thinking
about that craft.
But I think what it seems
like is that what you feel
is identical to
what we are doing.
And it's actually--
BETH MALONE: All I have to say,
what you bring to this room
is what "Fun Home" does to you.
You sit in that seat and you
brought whatever relationships
you have in your life
to this viewing today.
And that's the thing
you're feeling.
That's what you're feeling.
We do this thing.
We do the same thing
every day, and everybody
was like, oh my God, the
show was about suicide.
Oh my God, the show is
about mental illness.
The show was about being
gay and coming out.
It was like, it's about
whatever it's about.
You bring so much of it,
because there's so much
empty space in the show.
There's a lot of
room for you to fill
in your own narrative in your
own experience in "Fun Home,"
I think.
It's not super busy
and rattling your mind
with every measure
filled with-- cram-packed
with words and beats.
It's like there's emptiness
for you to show up.
ALAN SEALES: We're actually
running short on time,
so we'll do one
more question here.
Yeah.
JOE: Awesome.
Hi, I'm Joe.
I went to school for
music, and something
about the music
that really struck
me was that it seemed to
combine so many different
influences-- classical,
modern music.
And it wasn't one of
those musicals that
takes a great artist and makes a
musical out of their past work.
It really invents new music.
And I was wondering if you
could talk about your sources
for that, and if you could
talk about how you approached
writing for three
different people, three
different parts of their
life, and if the music matured
in any ways that you found.
JEANINE TESORI: Such
a great question.
You should probably
be composing.
Well, I have so much recall.
I remember reading Judy
Blume when I was at that age,
"Are You there God, It's Me,
Margaret," and thinking, God,
is this written
by an 11-year-old?
And she said that
she has this recall.
And I have that.
I have a kind of mind
that is complicated.
There's a bar mitzvah
always going on.
But every-- I remember-- I'm
not Jewish, and I'm straight
and it's just a
problem on both sides.
So I have so much-- my training
was so odd and wonderful that I
was trained classically, and
my piano teacher absolutely
demanded-- you know,
it's interesting we're
talking about space,
and I had space
to improvise and to do lead
sheets and circle of fifths
in everything, and to play
TV themes and pop music.
And I grew up speaking
four or five languages.
And sometimes people
have-- about my work,
they say it's pastichey or
it's eclectic, which means,
you suck.
In my world, that's
what it means.
Trust me.
But for me, it's that
idea that I am-- I
love what Beth was just
saying, that you are what
you bring to all these things.
And I find in "Fun Home," I
finally-- I didn't find it,
Lisa found it.
And because I am
all of these three,
I should be so lucky to
be these three people.
But we are these nesting dolls.
And I feel like a
nesting doll musically.
I love the Talking Heads,
and I love Stravinsky.
And I loved R. Kelly
"In the Closet."
I mean, all of that, all of
those things, and the beat.
And I was trained in
Nashville, and I finally
found this place where I could
access so much of those things,
trying to not apologize
for being so many things,
because I think a lot of women,
I don't know about people
in this room, were
taught, and I think told,
as I was, you are too much.
And I said that to someone
recently, and they said,
you mean too much for
them, for those people
who are telling you that.
And I thought, oh, if I had
known that 20 years ago.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: So Gabby,
has your relationship
with your parents changed
since you've been in the show?
[LAUGHTER]
JEANINE TESORI:
Your mother is here.
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO: Yes.
No.
My parents have always both
been very, very supportive of me
and very, very helpful,
and that has never
changed all of my life.
JEANINE TESORI: God,
what does that feel like?
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: Good job, Mom.
Good job.
So just last question here,
could be an upper or downer,
I guess.
You bring to it what you will.
What advice would
any of you give
to a child who suspects
that their parents, one
of their parents might
be gay, or a parent who
suspects one of their
children might be gay?
JEANINE TESORI: Gabby,
why don't you start?
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
I would say just understanding
that people have a right
to be who they want to be.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
GABRIELLA PIZZOLO:
Whoever they are.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
I guess that's it.
All right, well, everybody give
them another round of applause.
Thank you so much for coming in.
[APPLAUSE]
Cool.
Thank you so much.